[Musik]
schöns täglich
ich glaub new york und in paris new york
werden sinnspruch bestanden den vortritt
wunsch über lecke vita und setzte diesen
spruch hat sich die 23 jährige rahel zu
ihrem motto gemacht sie will leben und
spaß haben wie andere jugendliche auch
wie macht sie das davon handelt dieser
film
bild sie im entschieden sich viele
gekauft
schön stepping
rafael ist seit ihrer geburt zelebrant
gelähmt aus langeweile und weil sie
draußen nicht mitspielen konnte hatte
sich schon als zwölfjähriger geschichten
ausgedacht
bald merkte sie dass sich dafür abnehmer
finden
[Musik]
märz mit mami hat gold idec wunder und
man im bad die richtige schätze er hat
freunde zumindest völker das glück nur
das mitleid mir ist dass ich sicher zum
teil so weil ich am start das kann ihnen
reden aber ich denke wenn wenn es nur
das mitleid war fand ich mir nie träumen
bonität nicht eine nachdem andere fühlen
seit einem jahr darf sie sich vor diese
buchhandlung stellen ihre geschichten
mit kosten von freunden bis sie eine
reise zusammen hat schwarze jahre lang
und natürlich schränkt ihre behinderung
sie stark ein
die matildas wohnheim in zürich bekommt
sie die hilfe die sie braucht bei
gewissen dingen ist sie auf ihre
betreuerin angewiesen
aber ihre gute laune ist er dabei noch
nie abhanden gekommen
wie führt man sich fit
das ist honig vor dem vorstand bin und
nach unserem 7 und bürostuhl solchen
aber werfen und ist so viel glück kann
und gesehen und wie groß es ist
unvorstellbar wenn der b7 rufen poster
und dann plötzlich natur moment seit sie
aus paris zurück ist plant sie ihr nicht
das abenteuer gefunden dass die
planungsphase um machen zum teil nicht
so spontan zivi rucksacktourist nimmt
und frühstücken jedoch geht prima allein
hat sich super an den bächen a gekommen
linksys millionen der stütz handel mit
rechts machen eigentlich die ganze
arbeit
ja
dazu aus drängen sind ja wie soll ich
sage dir macht man einfach nicht weil
man fand ist groß aber ich würde also im
großen und ganzen hat zum beispiel macht
lernen wie brot streichen
ich finde einfach wieso funktioniert
wunderbar mit dem löwen ein großes ja
endlich mein geständigen aber das ziel
vor augen dass ich mal selbständig
wohnen und da muss man sie seit zwei
jahren lebt sie hier in dieser
wohngruppe ihre eltern sind geschieden
und nicht auf rosen gebettet zu hause wo
sie schon lange nicht mehr bis zur
totalen unabhängigkeit ist es allerdings
noch ein weiter weg
sie wäre eine bezugsperson und mir
vorstellen nach new york muss raffael
zwei pflege personen mitnehmen
eine allein würde die betreuung nicht
schaffen das macht die reise dreimal so
teuer
aber nun hat sie endlich das geld bei
sich das der grund für ihre mutter nicht
eigentlich erst fliegt auf dass nur
gewonnen haben und wie das tank passen
fast die hand ein anderer handwerker nie
sätze und vor allem ein klarer bestand
und das ist einmal in der woche darf sie
in die reittherapie das tut gut und
hilft ihre spastischen verkrampfungen zu
lösen
sie spüre coni dass man ihn bisher bin
ich jetzt meine zuvor durchlief er durch
den lions merkt dass sie kurt rowley das
und das ist cool es ist anfang mai in
einem monat geht es los nach new york
zum heim in dem reihe lebt gehört auch
eine behindertenwerkstatt ihr arbeitet
sie vier halbe tage in der woche als
telefonistin
was würden sie tun wenn sie ihren job
frei wählen könnte als kindern immer wer
lebt ihre ärztin werden jetzt wüsste ich
gar nicht weil ich stelle meine frau
nicht glaube meine periode
schriftsteller die werte um diese
wunderschöne frau zu ihrer körperlichen
behinderung hat rachel noch eine
lernschwäche
wenn das telefon schweigt stellt sie
geschenkkarten her das was sie dabei
verdient würde niemals reichen für eine
reise nach amerika und bettelbriefe mag
sie nicht schreiben
sie will es auf ihre weise schaffen ich
bin leben halt zwei jahren auf die
reichssportführer präsident selber oder
durch eine spende von 100 hier wenn so
zernig sport und das macht mich sehr
glücklich bin auch stolz drauf
spalten und die arbeit hier fühlt sie
nur selten auswahl hängt lieber ihren
geschichten und freut sich auf ihre
freizeit dann kann sie das was sie sich
ausgemalt hat wieder verarbeiten
ein schreib computer hilft doch selbst
das ist ein kraftakt funktioniert wir
schreiben das jahr 1790 prinzessin
christina in diesem jahr die königin so
langsam war und ich mache gern schrieb
und 081 nach gott darum bitten
cathleen zog das schmuckstück nur zu
ganz besonderen anlässen
[Musik]
der nachmittag ist noch lange nicht
vorbei ab geht's wieder vor die
buchhandlung das tram benutzt rachel nur
im notfall
sie wird gerne selbst und schnell
[Musik]
dass das wetter inzwischen umgeschlagen
hat macht ja gar nichts aus im gegenteil
franken
danke für gute unterhaltung
die schlacht an weiterläuft beste wäre
gut wenn sich aufwärmen und wenn es vor
lassen und bis zu einem meter hoch
cruiser und wenn dann meistens mehr
stress
[Musik]
noch liegen könne
ein totes andere shooter in new york und
mexiko und die rede ist schön wenn ich
nicht dort bleiben
die abreise naht in zwei tagen ist es
soweit
die schmerzen ließen die presse habe
keine angst ich bin die kinder wachsen
dass die zwei tage in mein zimmer sein
können und ich mich mich doch sehr wie
sich nimmt ja nicht ja und und jan
friedrich morgen werden es bestimmt
vergessen und darum wollte stuck und was
die anderen
nun spielt also sind sie nicht so viel
mehr bewegen wir mich schränkt die schon
lange gebraucht aber jetzt ist wenn es
nicht und so beim flipper league schoss
vorfreude meistens wie nicht immer alle
am flughafen begleitet und nachher wie
du musst drucker und abflug der große
tag
rachel ist seit 3 uhr wach und ziemlich
nervös
[Musik]
ihre mutter haben sich unbedingt noch
von ihr verabschieden
[Gelächter]
das gefühl dass dieses gesetz das zu tun
es geht
momentan eben in dem vielfach
auszuschließen
ok
ja bringt sowohl
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ja
[Musik]
nicht
in der schilderung entscheiden
juni
2016 jedes jahr knapp
für den schweizer umfasst waren ich lese
gras und das ist ein erlebnis für sie
[Musik]
eigentlich wolle man sich professor für
alle gerecht werden und dann plötzlich
mal was egoistisch liegt dass ich noch
lernen stelle kommt nach vorne mitfahren
ich was mir am meisten der start zur
mentalität von der lieth und wie sie
also ideal und auch mit stadt ist so
hier sehen zügigkeit architektur einfach
alle strom- und das ist unvergesslich
und dann wird auch klar warum sie noch
shopping geld verdienen wollte einen
wunsch will sich rahel nämlich schon
seit jahren erfüllen
diese kette und das geht nun mal los und
ich die schuhe
[Musik]
und noch etwas hat sie sich in den kopf
gesetzt einen drink in einer rooftop bar
[Musik]
nein
das ist noch nicht mal ganz zwei jahren
in amerika bin dass ich das geschafft
[Applaus]
[Musik]
neben